[Music]
you say the dodgy video no did you no
good welcome to true news you're dead
she loves being the good guy yes
juju did that 45 minute dismantling of
everything he'd ever said about it I
feel like that he's just been sitting
there sort of steering on being right
the bad guy and he hates it eventually
is like [__] it I'll be Lord Farquaad
now he wants to be in the right you're
going basically so you sure some text
messages
I really don't really care what he says
in the video nor fur I just don't give a
[__] anymore
I'm like three million people nobody
just goes mental at the end of the video
so I just want you to see what a
freeze-frame that should have be in the
thumbnail we're not here to say anyone
in this video is important or they're
not doing that fake outrage that a lot
of youtubers do whether they're like
this card carry on it we don't care yeah
but we're just talking about it it's
like sort of animal cruelty to someone
who eats for our grass they just know it
happens I thought you know what you're
talking about but it's so when you shop
a high street store that uses children
for labor you know it happens but you're
still where the clock exactly exactly
and if you want to get rascal truck sits
in an unrelated point you can find it so
yeah it's not sponsored really I think
one of the points that she was making is
I'm struggling mentally therefore you
can't sort of tell me I'm wrong now when
you've got them be they just cry mental
health
I'm not saying dead she did that but I'm
not saying he didn't do it either you
know when I said there was the
perpetrator hero victim thing mmm just
goes around man did you spin me right
round baby right round like a triangle
and hero just you know carrying all your
life not giving a [__] really [__]
agrees me
they really come through the screen
they're like I really I really felt what
he was yeah yeah what he's saying the
stupid girl you talking to my brother
why he will to me to me you had sex with
my brother and still had the audacity to
meet me
I'll see you have say to him I didn't
even tell me
what is your policy on sleeping with a
brother and a brother I wouldn't do it
yeah so you see how emotional he is
right now this was about four years ago
when the alleged sleeping with both
brothers happened now let's go back when
it actually happened we're actually the
same girl believe it or not she said she
like does he have whiplash from finding
out that JJ [__] the same girl I don't
know how that happened I didn't watch
doji but I don't watch him now some
things never change
this was this was awhile ago I didn't
know that she's banging JJ already but
she said she enjoyed my I mean
regardless of who she enjoyed more
that's what this is what the point is
what we're seeing now is a really
emotional meltdown about this from desi
when right after it actually happened he
didn't even care so dad was walking
behind him mother yeah that's weird
that's his father yeah I don't talk sex
with my parents all right who does these
guys he's tied to the background going
well she hasn't had the big man yet oh
sure let's collect the set just to put a
cup on this yeah in their ass he wasn't
that emotional about it right after it
happened and now he's extremely
emotional about it
I think his emotions oh it's the fact
that JJ just keeps winning the argument
against him right it's okay the emotions
change though sometimes afterwards you
realize oh I done [__] up I think it's
the fact that his frustration at being
the bad guy yeah yeah and the fact that
people only care about this channel when
he's arguing with his brother and that
must be frustrating yeah yeah so there's
no reason to stop then is there it's a
cycle that he keeps getting rewarded for
me so what maybe even subconsciously why
would you stop he's got a new music
video
juju you are
even with a balaclava rod Randall still
doesn't look like a rapper again it
comes back to that thing where the old
woman's looking out the window it's
always happens with these window all
these people in this block there's no
woman going George those boys are
outside again what are they doing
what is that young man doing put some
socks with holes on their heads say
they're with some girls though there
must be on some sort of date the tits
are gleaming yeah
they must have really brushed them well
with a date they're on earth but they're
going to go to the bowling alley
it's callous oh oh my god he's in the
new Oliver lay odds on love islands
decorate yeah we Sarah why of all the
influences 2.9 million subscribers
however the last three months four
hundred K to 21:58 280 K surely they
want someone who gets views now stay in
the quietest room and that anyone can
stay in a quiet room easy I don't think
I've ever heard you yeah he's been lucky
there's an e if he's gotten the big
money for that I think he's still he's
still got a cachet yeah the the
afterglow yeah when you've picked but
you're still sort of oh you're doing all
of Ola volleyer that's the best thing
he's done in ages you say it in a quiet
room is the sound trust of Howard love
keeping Monday tOA's be the topic in
discussion dad you said the wedding was
cheap he was right yeah didn't even get
a suit
kind of upset we didn't invite I'm more
upset I didn't get the oil of olay money
I would have been grateful that put it
on your face you're [__] oh I well if
anyone needs skin help yeah yeah you're
actually alright yeah actually hold on
and the weaknesses eczema what whoa whoa
whoa whoa I think this is look at this
little Hut and these tiny on he's got a
really small hand run he's got tiny
little hands don't worry he's like Ricky
Gervais yeah
on the plus side when he's having a one
it looks great so I've been told
yeah it is really surreal not really
like that it's kind of it's very funny
the thing is I know is it the rubber
duck rubber duck I don't know where he
comes up with these ideas but I'd love
to being in his head for so few days
also I'd love to see JJ's face we'd
Randolph when he goes when he shows him
the storyboards so she's birthing the
child there in an ambulance and then
you're still rapping she won a normal
real name what relevance is it that she
wants to know you're real she's having
your baby by now how is she still
needing in order come ought to put it on
the the father bit all right finally she
gets the government yeah well get baby
by him be a millionaire definitely not
wise JJ barely been in this video you
making an old man's hands I have to say
I no disrespect any things I preferred
cons music videos I feel that they are
equal in both ways log and new phone
mullet was gonna go viral so he's I [__]
it
he's a bit Matthew McConaughey's yeah
how you like to see me take my shirt off
but the guys did an interview you said
oh the slap wasn't an actual slap I've
been doing this long enough to know and
there was two cameras on there was one
camera on the left there's one camera on
the right now they showed that video
rich from the camera to the right of me
but they didn't use the video footage to
let these guys are profession
everything that you these guys are
professional everything they do you've
seen locum post Chun I guess plain
simple straight to the point did you
actually get knocked out from the slap
itself or was that all staged and faked
I was knocked out I know I had to I did
have my doubts I just don't think this
guy's smart enough to act that well did
you see him afterwards yeah me he was
gone I'd be much in MMA and fighting for
like [__] 20 years he falls down and
this is the thing faced out if you're
not knocked out the one thing you'll do
is your home from oh I like 300-pound
guy whatever the [__] he is heavy
bastard face-first into the grass like
there's no natural or better just break
this fall and make it look real he was
facedown there's no one who's gonna do
that this guy's no one's government name
go to Twitter Logan responded Logan
responded with this the dude is lying
through the skin of his teeth I think
anyone with a brain who watched his
video can see that he changes his story
every five minutes we paid him $300
place in the combination to show up
because he is the slap master he was
supposed to teach me how to slap based
on how I slapped him teach me form
technique where to hit etc this guy's
not smart festival he's charging Logan
Paul $300 anyone who lets people slap
them hard in the face for money is not
someone new smart Lawrence we had
already paid him his money he was here
he was supposed to teach me how to slap
obviously when I slapped him I knocked
him out cold and he's one of the first
things he sets him he goes you can't
post this video I'm just flat master I'm
like okay apparently not guy but at this
point I'm going balls deep so we
probably are gonna make it full-on mini
doc about this because I want to box him
I want a box to do it he thinks he can
mop me up in the ring I think he's what
he said so please brother come to [__]
in LA I messaged Logan after this yeah
he's just a little [__] fat idiot
leave it you know I mean if he gets in a
ring with this fat [__] he's gonna
[__] kill him he's gonna kill the
[__] guy let's be honest yeah
it's a lose-lose as Anthony joshua's
found out if you step in the ring with a
fat man it never ends well you beat a
fat man saw what the fat man beats you
or she
year of the fat man dawn [__] gone
near a guy he's got a Snickers leave him
alone chances are he destroys this fat
[__] and everyone's like bully Jeremy so
just like I'm just leaving let's be
clear loading this won't end well for
you
alright I just I don't have to threaten
you like that but you know you push me
too far
or Joe Simpson was joined Twitter assume
that I get the feeling that all that his
responses are gonna be about his dead
wife weirdly though someone tweeted off
of his account
I killed her I think oh gosh someone
yesterday asked me what the best advice
I ever got was don't use a knife my
mother said to me before she passed away
you can't let people and mean speech set
you further away from G - D I'm assuming
that means God she was about to die at
the time she couldn't quite get this
video up do you know what an old dude is
in front of the camera and they feel
like they're on a movie set yeah like
even these little videos are very like
forced now there's a lot of fake oj
accounts out there so this one at the
reload j32 is the only official one so
it should be a lot of fun
I think if anyone's got even to get got
even to be getting if anyone's got any
getting even to do it's not Oh Jay
Simpson it's the [__] parents of the
poor girl yeah and the [__] bloke he
murdered as well
it was orgy you can't say that what you
gonna do like see you did this dude must
not have much money left
that's what annoyed me
I was like how's he still rich
jealousy's no clear motion it does sound
very YouTube world walk about Sesame
Street guys welcome back to true news I
assure you by me I think he's a
legitimate letter from a child - Nigel
Faraj Nigel Faraj and his campaign of
pure honesty and delight continue as
Nigel Faraj receives a legitimate letter
from a 10 year old I'm a 10 year old boy
and I'm writing with a 10 year olds
vocabulary writing to express my
gratitude to you and your party without
you the leave voters would have nobody
to represent their opinions as the
majority of MPs in Parliament want to
ignore democracy spelled correctly and
overturn the referendum spell correctly
results at my school they talk to you
and brainwash us to be pro you me and my
friend Jim Jim fell Oliva fell Oliva in
brackets know their tricks from Matthew
a legitimate ten-year-old boy who smelt
nothing wrong had perfect home writing
and knows the word democracy and Russia
run referendum I was a smart kid
I couldn't have done this I was top of
my class therefore I would have written
this sort of [__] when I was 10 all
right but you were right in the labour
party
you [__] lefty if you're a boy you
don't you wondered the retweets black
mirrors buck mmm are you fun yeah I like
season 3 season 4 sometimes I got a
little bit oh boy smart so this is the
most interesting episode in my opinion
see he's just a normal dude and he's got
like a wife he's got a best mate so
they're like me and you but like cooler
right so these two guys start playing
each other on a game right so those two
black guys play this game where they
fight each other right these so they're
these two halfway through the game they
just start necking on for no reason
there's nothing I mean what you kissing
each other they [__] each other as the
video game characters but like they're
not like gay or anything like that okay
I don't know what it is and then
eventually every night when is mrs.
Costa Verdes like I'm just gonna play my
game right puts his little head piece in
like they don't feel a lot way about
each other it's only when they're in the
game so psyche well they're me it starts
pretty much where it begins
I've got no I'm not I don't want to play
Tekken with you either the other day
Brian said to me do you wanna play Mary
okay hot car more of a crush bandicoot
munch yourself crash my Bandicoot I
don't all right but anyway they get
right into it and it's just a really
weird one
Miley Cyrus is in this episode he's
plays a celebrity yeah and she's got a
doll like that's the doll and the doll
sort of comes to life sort of thing and
it's just a bit weird I mean she's an
all chaotic do you think it was
worthwhile for you three episodes
disappointed overall I think the
writings definitely gone downhill from
when it was a UK Shore it's too much
based on them like the production of it
now is what happen and the twists and
turns are a lot fewer in previous
seasons you've been like what where's
this going what's gonna happen next
whereas with for the Americans they've
dumbed it down and just made it very
like right this is it and then there's
very few twists and turns and yeah if
you're watching and you're from America
I'm not seeing your dumb I'm just saying
that when people write shows for you
they dumb them down for you and that's
why the last season of Game of Thrones
was [__] dumb and down sort of means
where it's not as clever mm as it used
to be so simple yeah so that you lot can
understand it yeah don't you worry your
pretty little head about it yeah as long
as you enjoy it that's all that Mars
snake of unveiled a new space
exclusively for women at its London
flagship shop showcasing plus-size
collection okay women's will Cup kit
even offering bra fittings at set right
so basically the point is they're using
mannequins that are plus-sized women
right and reflects on society yeah but
there's people sort of open arms saying
that we shouldn't be encouraging blow-up
balloon high overweight on door XXL
become a little fatty what do you think
about this because obviously there are a
lot of you know I think reality this is
what women actually [__] look like
like a lot of women don't get me wrong
the other man again some women look like
that some women look like the bigger one
right have options right yeah if you're
walking past an outfit and you see on
the little skinny mannequin and you're a
bigger person you're gonna be like I've
got no idea whether that would fit me
now they're gonna have a good idea they
may buy you that let's be honest the
world's changement we're not living on
[__] World War two Russians you know
people have got fish and chips and good
good hearty food like that do you think
part of it should be we should encourage
I'm not saying bigger people are all fat
because they eat too much some of them
have got the genetics and those kind of
things most of them it's just more
dollars do you think that we should be
encouraging people to also live a
healthier lifestyle so well yeah and I
think that making gym where for people
who are trying to live healthier is
going to help them because when you want
to go into a gym and you've got [__]
gear
yes but she is a woman because they care
about clothing more than men they're
gonna be a little apprehensive got the
gear called whereas they want to get
themselves in a gym they can now go and
do that and wear the same stuff as
anyone else and I just wish that they'd
do the same for men I'm [__] sick of
looking on clothes shop websites and
saying slim fit skinny fit suit and
going no good for me then not a chance
big men exist as well the thing about us
is where the Forgotten with a dying
[__] breed are you dying much women
are very good at making a noise about
things and good on them because because
they're now getting what they want
they're getting like good service yeah
fairly but men don't wear just like F
[__] it I'll just have to go to [__]
shops like Jack amore and stuff like
that you know which I refuse to do but
I'm sick of having to search high in law
for to excel general I mean I've got a
50-inch chest
I should not struggle to get a [__]
suit just because I lift weight I mean
let's be honest there's more than me
than that book but you do manage to find
them so well yeah make it easier though
that's what I'm saying do the same for
men everyone's bigger not just women
yeah well not everyone so okay then look
after ourselves right it's a joke okay
I've got no idea where this was taken
from but it looks like the [__] plane
ride from hell you love plane rides does
this make you feel any different press
play
[Music]
Brin yeah help me now love that would
[__] terrified me eat when I'm on a
plane just a little bit of turbulence
and I might I'm not new Gordon will you
go and I go we're all gonna die
you always soothe me done yeah yeah I
just I get mariokart
yeah but would it scare you because you
are such a sick bastard you you'd be
looking at me like oh this is what I
think even to our certain death you'd be
making a joke out of it right to the
bitter end right at the end gone oh what
a right people will not stop sending me
clips of this guy and they say we want
you to keep watching you and we want you
to keep going I mean the caravan so it
would be interesting putting on a fresh
pair of on the crackers in here he's so
weird isn't it it's like it's Gollum had
a blog when I was diving at one point I
ended up on a caravan site just like I
love Cameron yeah I lived on one for
like two months
homely aren't me no no they're not I
caught I didn't like it personally me
and my pal used to go out on the piss a
lot and let's just say the walls are
really thin almost visualize each
other's going on yeah to the beach
upgraded Caravan blag blag yes you went
to it we flew air Qatar Airways oh my
god he went to go are often do you I
have a look at this Rovin is from Goa
the idiot returns they filmed Robins
return to Goa oh there's a lot of litter
here you didn't tell me about that
[Music]
and they become really messy areas but
if you go to the right places and go you
get what the old guy used to be that I
grew up in the 90s because I saw going
it's best for and its prime peaked when
you were a kid about well you weren't
kidding it is a nice place this is
bringing about memories yeah if you come
with me to go I'll take you the best
things you won't see any other it's on a
new woman you never come back the rexes
why does he keep the camera right in
there yeah you do he's soliciting her
for sex is never know
oh god blossom we don't recreate this
and go with Brian I I don't know why
we've gone look a little red legs is it
no she's giving us feet a good scrub
that guy in the back long sweat pants
jumper and what's that headgear
it's Tobin okay I can dance he must be
sweating in gore you can identify a
domestic tourist just by how they come
to the beach so the women who wear saris
and the men who dress like this you know
they're not from God I can't understand
why he's put so much of this in can we
just check whether I think the chances
are he won come you know you got this
Buccaneers oh-oh-oh beat that meat beat
that meat be Nate what you're selling
men what you're selling he's doing an
accent and he's speaking in a basic way
it makes me feel wildly uncomfortable I
dig this one okay I take this one give
me a good price
no I just said that if he's asking for
150 rupees for the lighter which is that
that lighter should not cost you more
than 30 rupees okay but how much is a
pound this conversion so one pound this
is roughly now because they say that
roughly 89 rupees he said 150 rupees
yeah what's up like 150 yeah wonderful
[__] lighter lighter
he's bartering the [__] he wasn't kidney
is really cheap isn't he yeah but but
he's also been fleeced so even if he
calms down let's see he says the lighter
for 70 rupees that guy still gotta go
thought like us big enough to put a
household
Bin Ladin life sexy sexy lady did he
just hit been longer just too casual bit
of racism and you're away to the bar you
like God I just say if you want to see
footage from mansion house dinner shows
Tory MP mock field grubbing a Greenpeace
activist by the neck and forcing her out
of the room it's a climate change
protest basically so she's very keen
made her point he sort of pushes her up
against the wall and grabs her and then
pushes her out now people are sort of
saying that this was out of order
yadda yadda yadda what she invited I
don't maybe she was invited or maybe she
snuck into the party okay I don't know
the context I know that this guy's an MP
so he should know better but but what I
will say if you turn up to somewhere
someone's house which you know this is
an event place and you're not invited
security will often treat you worse than
this guy here the worst thing he did
well he shoved her up against the wall a
little bit yeah although I don't think
you would have hurt her and he's got a
grabbed her by the back of the knife
people are going crazy about this and
don't be wrong you shouldn't have done
it but let's all calm down she knew what
she was getting herself into
yeah some of the comments this
speed-dating really works
he got one in seconds now they just
waltz in no security good point there
the Conservatives have added security I
love the quality men and women should be
treated to say him I get it I think the
fact that she's a woman and he sort of
puts his hands on her and pushes her out
will trigger a lot of women who feel
like that shouldn't happen
and I get I get it and they're right if
a man went in there and he got trapped
that way it wouldn't be the same outrage
I also don't know if injecting equality
into it's really about how you treat
just other humans yeah I think he thinks
he's old school this guy he's like not
on my watch protesters I was about to
have my starter I'm [__] rich and I I
like to be a touring bastards I am a one
come because of brexit this guy's is
having a normal day and sure he's got a
boat and sure he's got a forklift truck
and [__] no way
no oh [__] you've lost it you've lost it
or doing stuff in No Child
then the [__] the forklift truck
starts moving oh my god that's terrible
almost go that's moving the boat oh no
it's another boat the boats got boats
definitely got the board's gone now you
notice the boat and then and now he's
running up say as fast as he can and
then he's useless freak that was you're
movin set of it I love how he hasn't
noticed a forklift truck it's gone back
this is a boat again that really is like
willfulness now as two people who grew
up as only kids I can never relate to
this however this is one parenting
technique I'm interested in this is the
getting along shirt when these two
brothers can't get on they put them in
the same shirt and make them stand next
to each other I love it yeah I love it
and now they're both crying good back in
the day people would if they were not
getting along and they were siblings
they'd be locked in there like cupboard
yeah the closet or whatever and be like
when you when you're getting along you
don't come out like that siblings will
just be a nightmare otherwise it's a
woman I knew she had like lost assist us
and apparently her mother would say like
if one of them told on each other she
got you one who did some wrong she like
did you do it alright you polished and
then the one who told uncle you're
punished as well for Talan on your own
sister I mean it sort of works but yeah
now this man is interesting we've seen
food reviewer we've seen blue van man
this man reviews old food oh my god is
he gonna eat that that's not a favorite
foods inside it well yeah but he's gonna
he's gonna open it yes could [__]
kill him I don't this is over a hundred
years old he might open it you're
supposed to be able to grab it by a ring
that was attached right here and you
peel away this one has a ring pole that
broke off years ago so someone decided
to not open it to things that I think
could be wrong there I think 20 minutes
ago he went we'll try and open this [__]
someone decided not to open this yeah
now if he was with bootleggers
bootleggers would go someone decided not
to open this Oh which someone was that
yeah you know at the other side that I
love is he goes someone decided not to
open it no mate this was it war they
probably got shot they probably thought
was a bomb look at it I wonder if that
edible
this is going to be edible right yes ink
was the last time one of these was eaten
I wonder I mean when was the last time
someone even open probably 100 years ago
you [__]
sorry he was hoping that it was gonna be
lovely and he could brag about us
fantastic yeah yeah I found this do you
know what I you know what I get the
feeling is didn't taste all that good at
the time you know so it's not gonna feel
it's not like a good one the guys at war
like yeah we just [__] shove this
down watch them get always shootin yeah
they're not like oh this is a [__]
gold meeow meeow meeow
is that fresh steak hmm this could be
really bad for you yeah I I doubt the
preservatives we're ready to cover this
for a hundred and twenty years later
he's eating an antique for foxy when how
long does this war go on for yeah could
be 200-300 years this put a lot of salt
but put it put an extra dollop of
preservative all right so I've been
boiling it for only seven minutes so far
that's curdling night
that's not boiling he's an odd guy
I think there's asbestos in your beef
although I do think that the food review
I probably went like 60 years ago where
his food like it was mental mmm he's
gonna reuse this pot no no no no he
tried out for the army they were like
nah me you're not gonna make him he's
like yeah I'll show you
you'll [__] regret this yeah and he's
on he's bought like a lord of little
world war memorabilia and there's a
poster there of a soldier on the wall
over the left and I was like okay eat
like a [__] soldier I won't do mmm
no you call me we've got all our rushes
yet yeah I'll find one 120 years ago
boom this is the real [__] right here
all you lot living in your mansions over
in Iraq Afghanistan I'm eating what the
real soldiers a enlargen you're not a
soldier in the Boer War in South Africa
you're a single man who doesn't how to
decorate in Wisconsin this is you're not
an assassin you don't have to do this
he could he could definitely die from
that you know I mean potentially like
[__] like this could kill people
easy he's taking massive bites of it
there could be anything in this this is
German food reviewer here he is doing
KFC welcome back to another German food
review and it's track of time from okay
FC Kentucky Fried Chicken here's mr.
Sanders I said I used to think that his
name was Kent okie I certainly never
referred to KFC carrier boxes
he has Mr Sanders that doesn't look
golden brown as well ah it looks yellow
yeah get to the [__] eating UConn
this very good mmm I like that flavor
even the original coating is nice but
the hot version is better and they want
hot Krispies please hot Krispies please
the [__] pig
the hot wing was coating missing that's
not good he's the tedious month so
anyway as a massive channel he has got a
big chunk well it's twenty nine thousand
subs bought he's getting big views come
come he go on to his channel what do you
want to see he inhales the burgers it's
like one bite is like almost a quarter
of a burger okay okay so let's go for a
quarter pound of them let's see how he
goes through these Wow his aesthetic is
very pleasing I'll give him that
that's a thumbnail and a half though I
do enjoy this video angle I do feel like
blue van man could take a little bit
from this not that way sort of turning
our so we're not supporting anyone all
over BVM no I'm just saying take from
the rather be enemies if we could see
them come together in a new night yeah
that'd be lovely
I mean for by told you he inhales for
boats it's amazing for baits for one
burger can you do that
now [__] get blue van man on not on my
watch that's enough foreigners for one
ashore worrying thing is some of the
audience will agree with that you know
we've done Goya we've had Robin you see
in Germans bucks a British he is
uploaded every day's upload in he must
film every meal this is our favorite man
right folks now this is a trip down low
you can see the pressures of youtubers
already taken its toll on him three
years later he is just going to be
uploading once a month one meal
disheveled you know you live lost like
for store and I can't bring myself to
record another [__] meal well I don't
think but I don't think they did it I
went round and I found I think it was 17
for sale signs outside the houses
basically ripped of all such a large
such a large I don't know is such a
large thing to do I've got 17 for sale
song hunt this happen I love the fact
that he was obviously really drunk at
the time but still sober enough to know
there was 17 we remember that 17 count
them I love his condom he's imagining us
watching this just as the audience there
was 17 of them these are doing sign this
sale sign well he ripped them up look at
the guns on him yeah drunken sadly not
so idea what happened folks a couple
weeks ago call them let's go whatever I
was doing a review on something and I
said that I used to eat ox own cubes as
a kid what's not going to do with the
for sale sites with it really what
happened to the for sale so I thought he
was gonna eat one of those built my
hopes up no [__] hell I am for sale
and people have been saying do a lot so
cube do a lot and Jun I says you should
do it really I love how he runs hit by
overnight home she there in bed as well
asking look under the us go so cute and
she goes I think you should Dave and he
goes it's decided then you just build it
up of and you do a chance yeah on you
got to do one thing Dave you give the
people what they want these people they
love
they love your stories and he goes don't
either the for sale sign story and she's
I've heard it too many [__] times 17
times 17 one for each side very beefy
whilst you think about Sookie was gonna
be tasted
what's worse this or eating second world
war food second world war food daddy
bought maybe we need to admit these two
join forces as well right yeah I think
David loved the tour of all food if I
went the war I'd love I'd love to be
next to him a little character it would
be our army dud this one is an espresso
martini
I don't like expresso martinis is that
coffee and martini basically very strong
coffee [__] he's working out he's
working out Churchill works this out
yeah oh right just say sensational our
other favorite setting is him in the
values the blue van man it's clearly
Brian a hot day oh yeah because he's
wiping his brow I thought a fish kick
was like sauce like burger side that's
the good it's [__] huge
that's huge could you have more mushy
peas as well please no usually when
something doesn't look good it very
rarely tastes good that is one of the
best fish cakes you'll ever have in your
life that is tremendous that is just
coffee and martini that is just fish in
cake so that's it for another episode of
true news yet on the true Dada YouTube
channel don't forget to subscribe on
Spotify and iTunes like the video
subscribe to this channel all that good
stuff thanks for watching and we'll see
you later find you ever worried that
someone's snooping on you so watching
all the time it would be annoying if
it's the government are watching us the
government it's a conspiracy they're all
watching The Listening on
hackers yeah ISPs well yeah under
government maybe the government well if
you want to protect yourself online then
expressvpn can help you do that
basically it's always on the background
of your computer and of your phone and
it just kind of keeps you to a degree of
anonymous online which i think is good I
always like anonymity
yeah that's why I've become a youtuber
expressvpn as the fastest VPN I've tried
it cost less than about seven dollars
per month you can watch all sorts of
events and sort of live things online
they do come with a 30 day money back
guarantee so if you're not happy your
money back I'm already happy just here
on that Illume it's time to stop pack as
a big brother from watching you cuz they
didn't ask you to be on didn't they this
year but you said no no they said you're
coming towards the end of your career
best to get on the TV yeah expressvpn
comm slash Geordie Youzhny the trusted
server technology